i am so curious if you could go back in
time and see
any band
uh in concert who would you pick and why
and i also need to know the year
i don't know not a band but i'd like to
see bowie
do his thing does that count
100 absolutely
maybe
i don't know what year i couldn't tell
you what year
someone else can choose for me
i would definitely see
um a tribe called quest probably in like
90
i don't know they had band troubles
a bit
so i would see them in like 94 or
something
before five died
um i'd like to see nick drake before he
died
um
and i don't i don't even he didn't
really do any gigs but
i would just hide in his closet that
might be wrong that might be insensitive
um
but yeah him
uh i i all that all very good answers
um what do you guys think um when you
were reading the script for the first
time after you got cast you're reading
the script what was like the scene or
scenes that you were most nervous that
you knew were going to be coming up mine
was a scene that ended up not being in
the movie so i didn't even need to worry
about it in the end
it was a scene
i don't know if i should talk about it
it's a scene
it was another
um
when emily has a bit of a meltdown but
it was in front of loads of people so i
had like bookmarked it in my mind of
that's gonna be really scary um
yeah but it ended up being really fun
actually so that's always good
uh there's this speech scene where i
have to give a speech while playing the
guitar uh and that was the scene which i
was the most excited for but definitely
the most scared of maybe they go hand in
hand um just because it was you know
balancing
the guitar technical side of it with
trying to deliver a speech with isis
throwing books at my head
all sorts of things were moving in that
scene
but yeah that was fun i mean there were
the the
the the performances that i was
anxious about
um but when it came to
um
acting i was
quite nervous for the
more comedy driven scenes because
i'm not super familiar with that
side of
this whole thing and uh
i couldn't name a specific scene but i
was a little
uh
nervous for that
i'm assuming you guys all listened to a
bunch of music getting ready for this uh
project
is there a band or any bands that you
listened to specifically for
the movie that you are still listening
to now i i like my sugar
i just love that the sugar is so good
thinks it's so funny
every time i say mushroom they're like
i'm like no meshuggah they're like
meshuggana and i'm like guys
[Laughter]
i was really into
death grips which is like a
is like a good
bridge between metal and
sort of the music i'm into is
newer and um
more hip-hop
but uh they're like really energetic
band that i listen to quite often
i listened i mean preparing i had to
listen to black sabbath a lot because
it's in the movie um
and i still listen to some of their
songs maybe different songs than i used
to listen to before and listen to yeah i
think i've
slightly
learned a bit more about them and yeah
found maybe some
more that suit my taste maybe
uh you you guys obviously the
uh uh machinery of torment is a huge
part of the film and i'm just curious uh
what it was like actually getting ready
for that specific song and knowing it's
gonna be like a huge part of the movie
in the third act quite terrifying uh
well
we had a couple
practices
we had a couple rehearsals together
um but for the most part we were
separated and constantly practicing
but it was pretty
magical when we all came together
um
and that specific
scene
probably it took like
two or three days right
um
three days yeah
and it was just physically exhausting
but one of the most satisfying
experiences i've ever
i've ever um felt during
uh acting as like just to be
completely
like have no
have no uh air in your lungs and to be
bruised and bloody but
i don't know there's something super
special about it to go all out and
release everything release all your
energy and
um anger
you guys are both like bleeding by the
end of it
pain it was painful
mental is pain
that's brilliant
yeah meanwhile you are throwing your uh
your bows at people
a person once
i'll
one of the things that i really liked
about the film one of the many things is
that all three of you are like real
characters you know like it feels like
these are three-dimensional characters
um can you sort of talk about that
aspect and how you each was it all
scripted were you able to add a little
bit of yourselves into the character
i would say emily definitely has
aspects of me and her she's also really
different to me but
there's definitely parts of her that are
very much like me and i drew from my own
self and
but yet things like
the
shouting and stuff we that wasn't
scripted um so that was really fun i
just got to
scream and go mental and and that was
really really enjoyable you don't really
get to do that very often so i enjoyed
that a lot
for for kevin for my character
there's there's like a very clear
um
arc that he has where he he's starts off
more timid and and
eventually finds himself and
gets more comfortable
in his own skin and and it gets more
comfortable speaking his mind and
especially against his
oppressive friend
um
and so it was it was a lot of fun and a
little
i when you when you're playing someone
it you're it feels like you're playing
two different characters when you really
you're not obviously it's he's the same
person throughout but um it's like can
be
disorienting when you when you don't
know
um
what what mind state this person is in
um
but but what helped really was like
the
i mean he goes through a hair change in
a
wardrobe and
like his physical appearance changes so
it was fun getting into that and and
really feeling
this change and
maybe this posture that changes or his
his attitude but yeah all that was fun
to discover
yeah i i think um
you to a certain extent when you when
you're
able to do a character you you you want
to kind of you do with the character
what you would be interested in seeing
um
and i think i i it was never explicitly
in the script
uh how how this was never explicitly in
the script but i thought it was most
interesting to have a character who was
driven by love and jealousy
um with hunter so in terms of if hunter
is operating from a place of um um again
it's not explicitly in the script but
it's how i uh what i wanted to bring to
him what i thought was most interesting
when i read the script um to have him
have feelings of love towards kevin and
for that to be the thing which is kind
of lying underneath all of it
um but again it's up to you know maybe
yep
end of answer
that note i'm just gonna say congrats
for real hope it's a big hit for you
guys thank you for giving me your time